Senate Republicans hope to hold a final
vote today on their tax overhaul but
they will have to overcome GOP concerns
about the cause President Trump tweeted
this this morning this is a once in a
generation chance obstructionist Dems
trying to block but it's actually
worries from within his own party that
are holding up this bill a report from
the nonpartisan committee shows the plan
will add 1 trillion dollars so the
country's deficit over the next decade
that is raising concern for some
Republicans the number-two Senate
Republican John Cornyn of Texas called
the study's findings completely wrong at
least for Republicans are still
expressing concern about the bill the
GOP can only afford to lose support from
two members South Carolina's Lindsey
Graham said yesterday failure is not an
option we need a tax cut our chief
Washington correspondent and anchor of
Face the Nation John Dickerson is here
at the table live and in color good
morning to you John yeah
two votes doesn't give them a lot of
wiggle room what options do they have to
move it forward well they're they're
trying to cook up some options I mean
this is one of the extraordinary things
about what's happening right now is they
are flying the plane while they're
trying to build it they're trying to
pass the legislation while they're
writing it and the problem is text
legislation is incredibly complex the
the careening effects of tax changes on
the deficit in the economy are complex
and so once you change something it
affects something over here nevertheless
they're trying to do this get this voted
get it done by the end of the day so
it's a bit of a rush if you had to call
the game right now what would you say I
don't call the game dickerson I don't
know I mean there is extraordinary
pressure to get this done to get
something done and so I think when we've
seen that kind of pressure act in the
past lawmakers find a way to get it done
and then they end up having to live with
the results of things shot through in
that kind of pressure environment but
Republicans have dismissed these types
of reports from non partisan groups the
CBO in particular and other issues when
it came to health care they're starting
to do it now so is it going to move the
needle at all well it gives some pause
to some senators and even if the report
from Joint Committee on taxation had not
been as troublesome as this one was bob
Corker and Jeff Flake the two senators
who were holding this up senators from
Tennessee and Arizona
have old-fashioned Republican fears
about the debt and deficit and if the
theory of this case is that cut taxes to
get economic growth going their argument
is but we for a long time have argued
that the debt and the deficit actually
hurt growth as well so you can't on the
one hand try and help growth with this
if on the other hand it's hurting growth
by creating a larger debt and deficits
so they're not this isn't crazy talk
this has been longtime Republican
orthodoxy and so in that sense what the
Joint Committee on taxation said helps
their case but really doesn't isn't
central to it they're they're arguing
something Republicans have argued for a
long time and a bigger problem for them
now that the trigger mechanism is not
being allowed by Senate rules correct
well that's right trigger mechanisms
this idea that will basically change
things in the future if it doesn't turn
out to go forward the way the authors of
this tax plan say they're hard to craft
because they can have downside effects
on the economy and then also by the way
what happens is when you get to the
trigger point everybody says oh never
mind let's get past the triggers so it's
very hard to create this kind of thing
and there are economic reasons you
wouldn't want to create it anyway which
give opponents a substantive reason to
be against what corker and flake are
trying to do so John let me ask you
about this as you know CBS News has
learned that chief of staff John Kelly
has seen a plan and approved the plan to
replace the Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson with the CIA director Mike
Pompeo is Tillerson dead man walking and
how difficult must it be to do his job
well I have it's I'm trying to think
back of an instance in which you've had
a coordinated effort by an
administration to say here's your hat
what's your hurry I mean they are they
are showing him the door publicly which
means a obviously it undermines him in
because the Secretary of State has to
speak for the president so obviously he
is not speaking for the president
because the entire rest of the
administration it seems based on the way
this has been coordinated is saying he's
not long for this job so you've got to
wonder then kind of well okay why not
just get it over with and it also it's
extraordinary when you look back and
think about one of the arguments for the
president was that he came from the
world of business I don't think you
would have this situation in the world
of business where you just let a
secretary of state kind of twist in the
wind like this so
the if there's gonna be a change it
probably needs to happen soon because
real things are happening the North
Korea issue is heating up yeah we've got
but did he really have a chance after he
called the prayer reportedly called the
president [ __ ] if you really have a
chance assist well I don't know I mean
that's obviously was not great yeah
great for him but one of the things this
president has allowed at least from his
Secretary of Defense and others is
people with strong opinions to voice
them that on the other hand he is part
of where the clash has been between the
president in his Secretary of State yes
you voice them and then the word
embattled comes before your name that's
never a good sign
thank you John thank you very much and
Sunday on Face the Nation John talks to
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham White
House budget director Mick Mulvaney and
independent senator angus King no
relation that's Sunday right here on CBS
yeah